you said in your interview with the
times that Nigel Farage had become a
snarling thin-skinned aggressive man why
did you say that what did you mean well
what I'm getting at here is that is the
public face which too often during the
campaign people saw now if anyone thinks
or supposes that I'm planning some kind
of coup against Nigel they couldn't be
more wrong he is my political hero and
will remain so and he's taken you kit
he's done amazing things and I've been a
loyal supporter of his leadership for
all the way along but he has
unfortunately fallen a couple of people
in his inner circle who to use it a one
per term are Romans in my view and I
trying to influence him in a direction
which is night of productive for you Kip
nor even more importantly at the moment
productive for the general campaign to
get Britain out of the EU and that
should be number one objective as you
keep members now is to maximize the
chance of Britain voting to leave the EU
in the next couple of years and no one
should have any truck with anything that
puts that gold in jeopardy